[Music]
they served our country and you'd hope
they'd get the care they deserve but in
one case the 8 news now i-team is
uncovering tonight a veteran may not
have received life-saving measures he
should have vanessa murphy has this
story you only see on 8. now we do want
to warn you some of the video is
disturbing
this is an 88-year-old marine corps
veteran he's at a v.a medical clinic on
the east side of las vegas on june 7 of
last year this video leaked to the eight
news now i-team because of concerns
about how this veteran is treated after
a medical episode we showed the video to
neurosurgeon scott glickman who runs his
own medical office and an attorney
larissa dr hobitzer who says she has
experience in medical malpractice so
they can both weigh in about medical
care and the response time of staff
here the veteran is seen struggling and
then collapsing a bystander immediately
tries to comfort him more than 30
seconds later an officer arrives and
appears to call for help where's the
nursing staff or
doctor staff or
some
tech person there's a puddle of blood
underneath the veteran's head which gets
worse by the minute hey tick tock it's
seeming like a long time already two
minutes later this woman whose sources
tell the i-team is a nurse arrives here
comes somebody with a monitor she's not
moving very quickly she appears to check
for a pulse at three minutes she removes
his mask i would have expected maybe
somebody to start cpr or
some kind of resuscitation
she's saying get over here
she's got the aed the
defibrillator
there should have been much more fuss
much sooner
i would expect at four and a half
minutes so one person the lady in blue
finally comes running she begins cpr but
dr glickman points out no one is
delivering air to the patient there's
multiple people around
that
could be helping how critical is this
situation
he is dying
after 11 minutes the clark county fire
department shows up they assess the
patient and do cpr as a team and appear
to deliver breaths it's commendable the
veteran is taken to a hospital and
pronounced dead it's sad it's it's
emotional that
you know somebody you're in a facility
where
you think that you're going to get
medical attention and you think you know
people are going to run to your rescue
and that's just not happening here
you could assume that there would be an
older population
that would be
visiting
this clinic
and that they would have
proper policies and procedures to deal
with
a medical emergency the eye team sat
down with the head of the va health care
system in southern nevada do you think
care was delayed hands-on care to this
patient
so without getting into the details of
that patient i i would have to say no
what we didn't tell william karen at the
time of this interview is that we have
the video i'd say we responded
accordingly that you would see in any
other
health care clinic of that nature he
says all clinical staff are trained in
basic life support and cpr but he also
tells us after this happened his staff
did a refresh on emergency management
procedures i mean i would think in a
medical setting like that you should be
able to get more
life-saving care yeah yeah it's not
unlike a hospital setting there's no
crash cart there's no cold blue response
but as dr glickman points out air still
could have been delivered to the patient
sooner
the biggest
fail on this
is that they did not
put oxygen on the patient
immediately and they did not
deliver breaths for
10 minutes just this morning after the
va learned we have the video a spokesman
sent a lengthy email stating mistakes
were made that led to a delay in
initiating basic life support suggesting
the delay was caused in part by a
transition of staff and management due
to the pandemic i'm putting the entire
statement at eightnewsnow.com
also the i-team tracked down the
veteran's family his daughter tells me
they were not aware of any video or
delayed care she asked us not to
identify her father and the family was
told he died of a heart attack we've
learned no autopsy was done to help
determine an exact cause of death so we
don't know if the delay in care
contributed to his death
vanessa murphy live local now